[Applause]
seniors President and Mr
President of the European Council,
ladies and gentlemen, it is
exactly five years to the day
that your Parliament has placed its
trust in my committee and you
have never denied it, it
is true that we have sometimes had  relations
difficult but always polite
tumultuous but orderly and I wanted
to thank you wholeheartedly because
having the confidence of this
hemicycle the power to rely on the
confidence of European elected representatives reflecting
European democracy and for
everyone who receives this confidence a
honor that lasts I see
many familiar faces here who have
become friends
not only interinstitutional but
for opinion and so I wanted to
thank you wholeheartedly just as I
would like to thank the President everything
that we were twin brothers
but even  twin brothers can
sometimes disagree but we
had the smarts to  hide our
disagreements and so for you it's
probably surprises that
happened to us to have disagreements but I did
n't want anything it's donald for his
unfailing complicity for a friendship
that will remain and who led friendships we
use this word to  twists and turns in
politics are rare especially
within the same political family are even
rarer within the same political family
but without donald i could
not have done what i could have done i
would like since i m  address for the
last time to this hemicycle also to
wish
Mrs Fanta good luck and she is the
person we need at the head of the
committee and who needs our
encouragement and to wish us good
luck
and I wanted to thank  also my
commissioners because without them I
could not have done anything they are
men and women who
individually and collectively have
deserved well from europe
and thank you for that you social at auriga
d'ogm is a film so when  that I took
office in
2014 europe has in fact been weakened the many
cracks and breaks in
solidarity europe in 2014 was unloved
which leads me to talk
about the last chance commission but i did not want to
not to speak of the commission m of a
commission at the service of europe which
was broken down since we approached in
2014 a crucial moment in the city to
become of europe and therefore we were
all trying to give life to the
last france  which presented itself at the
gates of europe
I had chosen together with my
colleagues to set up a
political committee
I wanted the commissioners to
be elected apart from the British commissioner
I had two British commissioners,
one more action than  the other, all
commissioners were elected
either nationally or at european level
i wanted the commissioners to
be known faces in their country and in
europe
i had invited them not to
shut themselves up in bruxe  lles do not sink
into the berlaymont but two
ray circuits to explain dialogue
with other elected officials and with public opinions
and therefore the citizens we
have organized during these five
years 1800 1815 citizen dialogue and the
commissioners attended and visited
900 x 911 times national parliaments
and regional parliaments at the start of
my mandate I promised you that the
committee would focus on
the essentials
to be big big and I wanted to m we
wanted to put an end to the
legislative inflation which until then until then  'at
that time characterized the action of the
commission of the have done so since
we presented 84% of the initiates
of legislative initiatives less
compared to the previous commissions
we withdrew its 42
legislative proposals and we modernized 162
existing laws which is better
we have done everything to do what
we promised but that does
not prevent each other from continuing
the game which cons  ist to reproach the
commission for being too sprawling to
take care of everything prejudices prejudices
have life held in europe
everything has changed we acted as if nothing
had changed when I
appeared before you I was three
words other than what I wanted them to
dictate the conduct of the commission
growth employment and investment
we are experiencing the 25th
consecutive quarter of growth we
have led this year of growth
in the european union
we have created 14 million  jobs
the false market
and the lowest since 2000
241 million europeans are at work
an employment rate of 73 9% playon
cairo generated
investments of around 430 2 billion at the start then
that we think that this Castres plan is a
failure
empty talk we were talking about lead
a war now that it is a
success we are talking about the European
fund for strategic investments
so goes the story one million jobs
have been  e created thanks to this plan and we
have given another reading grid
to the stability and growth pact by making it more
flexible in some of its
provisions we have done so against the
will of many many
member states who have never  formally
approved the flexibility lines with which
we have enriched their Kabyle patrice
but the result is there the deficits
have gone from 6 6% to 0 7%
this know-how
intelligent flexibilization of the stability party has
enabled us to respond
when Spain and Portugal  italy and
greece we were asked to act in
their favor
i have known my dear friends in the world
world to disappointments and successes
disappointment because despite our
efforts we have not succeeded in
moving the files forward  of Cypriot reunification
there still too lost we were not able
to conclude a treaty with
Switzerland in spite of our efforts which
were numerous numerous and intense
we  we have not succeeded in not creating
the banking union
not for lack of proposals from the
commission but thanks or for lack
thanks or not for the efforts of the member states
also we do not complement each other the union
bank has committed the wrong by creating
the economic union  and monetary
a banking union that characterizes
monetary unions everywhere in the world
we will not be ready to react to the
next shock whether it is internal or
from outside promised
it is that we have to do there is
the ardent obligation which should be
another to put in place a
deposit guarantee system without deposit guarantee
no banking union and are without
deposit guarantee no banking union
and without a without a perfect banking union
more union  economic and monetary situation, we
have to know how to react to these challenges and we
have also experienced successes, despite the multi-
crisis that has been ours
over the past five years,
I dare not say successes
because I would not like to pay  in
self-satisfaction
although I feel like it but we have
had successes
first of all I want to mention the
social dimension of the european union unloved child
over the past decades we
have been able to adopt the pillar of
social rights I  recalls that during my
first appearance before separately
as young Minister of Labor during
a Luxembourg presidency this
speech was already mine at the time
even before having approved the pillar of
social rights we had put
on the job
the directive on  the secondment
contrary to expectations
we managed to bring parliament and
council an agreement was all the same
it seems to me a success of this
commission to have erected in principle the
fact that for the same job and for the
same  work
we should have the same salary the
dignity of the workers and is at this
price and moreover if we think we can
build europe make it prosper
without having the consent of  those who
work we are seriously
mistaken europe must also be that of the
workers
another success, it seems to me, greece
I am talking about it because it kept me
busy and preoccupied
we have given greece the dignity
that  it is fitting to give it too
often and for too long we have trampled on
the dignity of the Greek people
I wanted to restore the order of things
by reasoning with this people all the
titles of nobility they deserve
we wanted to prevent the commission from  act
in favor of greece i remember the
long nights with the
samara and brasse governments and now mottaki
this ticket is not yet in business
where we tried to solve
problems
the greeks and many
many were the governments who
did not want  that the commission takes care of it
I will always remember the
phone calls of several prime
ministers who told me mind
your own business
it is the sphere of state to take care of the
Greek problem alo  rs that I had
this naive conception does not exist
that we would have to respect the treaty
they treated says that the commission
right hours
and the treaty says that the commission is
in charge of the general interest
of europe
it was  in the general interest
of avoiding the breakdown of the
euro euro zone and therefore we were right to
do what we did
africa africa yes european we cannot
forget our first neighbors they are
african it is  a continent that
needs our solidarity is not
just our charity, charity
and an old reflex of Europeans, whereas
today it is a question of setting
up a true equal partnership
between Africa and  europe
investing in africa creating jobs in
africa this must be the leitmotif of
our action and not seeing africa
solely through the prism of the
refugee crisis has hurt their
honor africans that  considering
relations with
Africa  only we are al askri the
refugees but let's do what we have to do on the spot
so that the unfortunate do not
throw themselves into the oceans the rockets yes
success or not the bills we are better
than we thought but it could be
even better if the council, as
did the parliament, had followed all the
proposals that the commission had
submitted for consideration by the co-
legislator,
a first part on localization in
March 2015 and another in April 2016 on
the reform of the dublin system
but let's not forget that thanks to europe
we were able to save
seven hundred and sixty thousand lives in the mediterranean 7,760
fewer deaths thanks to the action that was
that
of europe and then it is the only survivor
who applauds j  said in March 2015
what we are going to do in terms of
refugees he even speaks applauded standing up
he said so today you
ask me are you sure that
in two years from now you will applaud me  and
always the applause was
thinner the years later because
in many countries domestic politics
took over
the land element solidarity and which should
have been ours
I got busy when I
did not think about it when I arrived at
the  head of the international trade committee
difficult subject highly controversial
in all our countries with often good
arguments arguing against trade agreements
done in a hurry but
we changed that we concluded
that an international trade agreement
we have today
trade agreements with 70 which reflects 40%
of global wealth the treaties and
louis mousse us is to be present on
the international scene at a time when the
united states tons of water to
multilateralism and therefore to
organized solidarity with others i  love usinor
they will tell you euros pass in heaven
and cranes stoehr pga form of sourness sly
stone brad pitt of state sardos girl dan
fried in europe penny
s do they find
adam speak the still creek val done
when we get complicated you shout that I
nature field of dreams territorial d
europe and one to the territorial stats
of aldershot launches blues chris noth
asked jean ferrat gundotra latin
d  africa of the nations can which debuts
[applause]
in this new same young people is put between
my two boys in europe at
antenna donchery pierre adam abou sofiane toumi
the raid
he will distribute in europe and i am
continental machinery winfried
a ride
mendy directly to the income post
below click or 6th big three
dimensional lag in time is also
fragile says leizer europe and a
commission the drpj union she is
human
moossmann funky good fridays infancia
scanner au permis games is a big
party big parties at a  critical in
talent to the water moossmann of trees and 12
in scred a saga saw nike face creeks
of the delta where you have with hospitals
but despite my life hurdes have  they
may cry country of lightning human
muslim in europe in gold perspective
foundation to the gangster to clear
resistant tubes 0 2 int france
continues to imagine opinion in the united states
which is declined in europe and I continue
policies attended stuff
put demographic and graph
under amended by a script in political
dick and graphics tarnos lived
in the terrines had restarted a
fine foundation nino transforms 6% of
raids european relief home and
iron and steel design percent in europe
and opted billions of
gibbs machines  then to denver troy lee chan
craft and massive bus in serious danger
a way a turn kaman sega europe
and mikic youth of a gay militant
sable group zain division to an
area of al ghiran 10 sheets visib
e damage but there are ten nicht
or  craybas gorgeous notting hill
sphere moments that kobe a view of
the national ausy group gala enter obviously
stuff super league editor's note so fundamental
eu  ropa fried europe and the bartery that
in resistance zink de denver to his
music a practical darroussin phrase
under the spa resell rule or nextradio
this film makes us finished he predicts renoir
ahmar fled his sphere on friday to
right-wing politicians
doss the  europe in europe with kate and
needs reinhardt a law has he made
in france reported them to us spa
president 30 episodes where lana
lang lang für das magazin 4 000 soak a
phase and that can't slow ski but
wildlife prime ministers president  of the
castle will be opened by oracle r
president commission
it is unheard of joe all orders and
would do in its members nor the
extraordinary thing cyclical the offal
immigrants füle deserves the goals this a
time 20 years lanig bassa and gets angry with
stars of  verne planetside form of a
film peter klein stalin scored on
a big season
girls stylists take care
of europe and fought it with all
your might
stupid nationalisms  and bornet long
live europe
[Applause]